reste que la plupart des liaisons tgv
entre paris et la province sont annulés
jusqu'à demain le trafic aérien a été
lui aussi fortement perturbé d'une
manière générale les responsables de la
sécurité civile recommande à chacun de
renoncer à circuler que ce soit par air
par train ou en voiture
état des lieux avec thiriez il ne
partira pas il restera à quai la cause
la tempête voyageurs dépités tgv
immobilisé le trafic ferroviaire a connu
un dimanche exceptionnel aucun train au
départ et à l'arrivée sur paris excepté
paris lille paris rennes et paris nantes
aucun trafic en lorraine très grosses
perturbations à lyon et jusqu'à 19
heures en haute tarentaise
aucun tgv au départ de marseille et ce
jusqu'à lundi matin
mais le trafic devrait redevenir normale
dès demain matin excepté de sud est un
numéro pour se renseigner
08 36 67 68 69 trafic de banlieue prévue
demain gare saint-lazare très perturbé 1
train sur 3 sur la ligne b et d du rer
ainsi que paris est et paris nord en ce
qui concerne les avions le trafic a été
rétabli à la mi-journée les aéroports de
roissy-charles-de-gaulle orly bâle
mulhouse et strasbourg ont été fermés de
longues heures et d'ailleurs bâle
mulhouse et strasbourg pourraient bien
refermer à orly huit avions de
différentes compagnies ont été
légèrement endommagés ainsi que
plusieurs structures et systèmes
informatiques secondaire selon edf
huit cent mille à un million et demi de
personnes serait ce soir encore privés
d'électricité régions les plus touchées
la bretagne la vendée l'ile-de-france
les vosges et le jura
edf recommande de ne jamais touché une
ligne électrique tombée à terre au
dessus d'un axe la rochelle colmar tout
le réseau routier a été touchée on ne
compte plus les arbres et les panneaux
arrachés ainsi que les routes à
circulation alternée l'autoroute a13 est
coupée à orgeval ainsi que la a14 vers
paris province l'a86 est coupée à
maisons alfort et l'on prévoit pour la
soirée de gros embouteillages en
direction de paris